[Music]
on today's show we talked to a deployed
veteran who is missing his kids and they
are struggling at home and he wants to
know what to do we also talked to a
woman who is married to a brand new
police officer and she wants to know how
to be a great partner and we talked to a
woman who is married to a deadbeat stay
tuned
[Music]
what's up what's up this is john with
the dr john deloney show
man hope you all are doing well hope the
world is spinning right where you live
man we got controversies everywhere we
got drama everywhere we got people
hurting everywhere
so i'm glad you took a break from all
the chaos to join us on our
chaotic neighborhood here so glad you're
here don't forget
man's book is out i don't
i feel
i don't wanna keep talking about it but
i wanna keep talking about it i'm
excited about it on your pass change
your future go to johndeloney.com still
in pre-order you can buy
it now and you get a month free
counseling better help by the way shout
out to better help man for stepping up
for that
they didn't have to do that and them
getting behind the book on the message
and us and more importantly you it's
pretty rad
um
james benjamin kelly everybody good
yeah those are lots of thumbs no words
just thumbs i'm good
nothing oh some coaching did that go out
over the year
uh no i did not but this is okay james
gave me some feedback in my ears just
let y'all know it hurt my feelings let's
go to keely out in hastings nebraska
what's up keely how we doing
doing well sir how are you good brother
so you are um kelly told me you're
deployed is that right
yes sir awesome man and i won't dig into
all this the
what's in wears and wins but i just want
to tell you i'm grateful for you
wherever you happen to be on the planet
thanks brother thank you so
my question for today sir is how to
help my seven-year-old process trauma
and feelings
in general especially while i'm gone
like so she
sorry oh you're good brother
so we had adopted her like two and a
half years ago out of foster care um
pretty rough
first two weeks of her life
mom super flaky
had guys in that of her life all the
time right to the point where
mom didn't know who bio dad was so 10
dollar house
um
and just really
i struggled like
earning my yearning trust and wanting
like even like being around me you know
right though yeah
because she
had if i say 15 20 guys in that of her
wife in the first two and a half years
it's not good
so it's trying to figure out how to
help her process
that and work through that trauma that's
what's with me being gone
um
she was just diagnosed adhd
a couple months ago hey brother talk
talk directly into the phone there okay
sorry okay you're gonna know adhd okay a
couple months ago which we kind of
figured but
trying to get medication figured out
that's been tough um
and
just like working like temper tantrums
and
having accidents like she
would do great you know for five six
seven days of having an accident and
then in the past i would say two weeks
it's been every day yeah and it's like
it's a control thing
you guys are just like really struggling
and then when she has these tempers and
she has these meltdowns
they've been increasingly more
aggressive like the other day she was
mad at my wife
because she had an accident and started
throwing like car seats and my wife in
the vehicle and shoes and
so like we don't know how to help or
process all that yeah but on the other
side she couldn't be the best little
girl ever
you know like
really feels people's feelings and
empathy
but
it's like a flip of a switch like one
minute physically one minute she just
snaps and we don't know how to help her
awesome
well first and foremost man
um
a lot of my work behind closed doors is
with dads who don't care
and
like just
just between two dads or two little kids
man
um i'm grateful that you're out in the
world
building the world that my kids are
going to inherit i'm grateful for you
that you care about this little girl i'm
also grateful man that y'all took her in
um you have any other adopted kids she's
the only one
no sir we have a two-year-old and a
three-year-old so we adopted
mid to late july two months before i
deployed so okay was your deployment a
surprise
um it
there's rumor
but there's always a rumor he adopted
yeah we got the two little ones july
22nd in july 28 i got the call saying
hey you're leaving september 29th gotcha
all right so it was kind of stressful
um
here's a little bit of context and then
i can give you some
hopefully we can reframe this a little
bit and then we'll give you some tactics
okay some strategies perfect the the big
thing here is this um you may have heard
me say this before
but whenever we see a dog
on the side of the road
and when you go up to pet that dog and
it just starts growling and it attacks
you
most people with
a shred of compassion in their soul
immediately thinks
what
sob hurts you like what who treated you
this way that my stick in my hand not to
pet you and show you love
um
hurt you like this right
and so we often forget that when it
comes to people especially kids and so
what i want to do is take off all of
your i the thoughts of control the
thoughts of
manipulation i want to take all that
language that's that's off the table for
a while
okay
what i want to hear is not that your
girl your baby girl's a dog don't hear
me say that but
your baby girl is a dysregulated
trauma survivor
who's got a little bitty body who's
trying to figure out what's safe what's
normal and everything in her life up
until two years ago was not safe and not
normal
and then
an incredible man came into her life
and for a five-year-old
a six-year-old you were like you were
number 21 right you were dude number 21
and then you earned it and you earned it
every day every day every day baby step
tiny step tiny step earning it through
every little hug every little smile
every little you kept doing bedtime you
kept doing bedtime
and then you had to get you got deployed
and so
we have this little girl i want you to
think of her right now it's just a
nervous system
that's still trying to figure out what's
up and what's down okay
and
anything that's going adhd is a
neurological it's a body's response to
chaos and that's what she's experienced
her whole life until she came into your
home right and by the way we also added
two new kids and if you had if you you
had a six-year-old biological kid with
no history of trauma and you brought in
a two and a three-year-old you're going
to get 10 percent you're going to get
all behavior that at the neurological
level saying hey notice me what about me
do i still matter and then you put all
the trauma and the disregulation on top
of that and any physical or sexual abuse
she's experienced or seen
and man you've got a totally
dysregulated
cpu in this child right and then you see
it
oh my god she is a beautiful sweet
loving girl and when she feels safe and
her body feels safe then man then you
see it and those are those moments that
you know
we're playing a long
long term game here
and the cornerstone of all of this
healing that's going to happen in your
family is going to start with you and
your wife making sure you all are
connected making sure you're well she's
well and even when you're on deployment
even when you're home that y'all's
marriage is really strong that you're on
the same page about things you're gonna
have to be the best communicators of any
people you know because that's what the
kids are gonna anchor into
and what i'm telling you is there is
healing in this deal have you do you all
have any sort of trauma counselor she
works with i guess she just got a
diagnostic so she's working with
somebody she
she has been going just going to see a
therapist for the past i'd probably say
four years she's a play there but so
right now lily will see her
every other friday
i've heard some magic with play therapy
one of my mentors was a play therapist
um and i've done a little bit of play
therapy and it's it's remarkable for
connecting
i've heard extraordinary things about
equine therapy with kids in this
situation
and that may be something to consider
and insurance has picked it up in
certain places and so that may be
something to look at too equine therapy
where a kid learns to manage and
navigate
and join a relationship with a horse
and there's something
magical about it and i don't fully
understand it i've got some friends who
are equine therapists and it's
remarkable but it teaches them a
level of stability and power and control
with an ex
credibly empathic animal and it's very
big it teaches them strength and renewal
of their own power but she's in a
playthrough which is awesome
um here's a couple things that i would
talk through with your wife as she
navigates these things the big one the
big big one is don't take these things
personally
and we we think when a kid has a temper
tantrum when they're snapped when they
scream and when they're hitting things
whatever
that we're somehow failing
a kid who is having action you're
talking about bathroom accidents right
yes sir yeah
man
the best you can
lean into that with
i'm so sorry because the kid doesn't
want to be doing that
and there's a shame associated with the
shame is what causes the screaming and
the yelling and the kicking and all that
stuff the anger the rage i can't control
my own i like i know what a normal
six-year-old seven-year-old is supposed
to do and not pee their pants or not go
the bat right
and so it's hard as that is
to clean up yet another mess and yet
another mess and yet another mess it's
leaning back into that and saying hey
honey she can be a part of cleaning it
up but we're gonna work through this
together
and not taking it personal and that's
hard is your wife struggling with that
she is yes okay
do you struggle with that i do
yes i i mean i said she can be so good
for so long and then
it happens and then she won't
even be honest if i don't nope i didn't
do it i mean it doesn't seem like it
doesn't faze her well just understand
that her little bitty six-year-old
seven-year-old brain
if you acknowledge that may have gotten
her
smacked in the face
that may have gotten her kicked out of
her mom's
room when she was three or four get away
from me you're disgusting
or these diapers are like you don't like
the backstory here
can be it's the depths of hell
and lying for her is a defense mechanism
not a character issue like you and i
does that make sense
yes sir and so what we want to do is
teach that we're safe
and that we're going to call dishonesty
out for what it is
but it's going to be a teaching not a
not a character thing
i hope that makes sense
um i want to give a pass on that
especially for a traumatized abuse kid
um
how's your marriage man i know this got
to be un i mean if i'm you i and tell me
if i'm wrong i'm feeling powerless i'm
feeling like i'm doing this thing on
deployment which i signed up for and i
know it and i'm grateful for the mission
all that stuff but god almighty dude my
wife's in hell and i want to be home
like that's the mission right how are
you feeling um
um the marriage is okay now like we
really struggled there for probably six
months towards
you know the
beginning middle of 2021 okay just a lot
of
my own bad decisions
which
we're working through um
working through that and trying to
help the girls see that hey mom and dad
are working mom and dad are okay they
were safe you were safe
just
and then this deployment came up right
towards the end of
those
issues
being resolved so kind of through a
whole new wrench of things yeah
um are you in a place where
not through
text messages but where you and your
wife could start pen paling each other
on paper
yes
i would
highly
highly recommend that
that you and her commit to a weekly back
and forth i'm gonna put a stamp on it
old school like it's world war two
yeah i'm gonna sit down and i'm gonna
write this and it might be little it
might be minor it might be me vomiting
up how mad or angry i am how much i miss
you whatever and vice versa
but i want you to commit to that
and i wish there was something less
cheesy and less
simple but there's some kinetic
connection there that happens when you
sit down and write stuff down and then
put it in an envelope and mail it and
then there becomes this apprehension i
can't wait
to get my letter back
and it it's almost a throwback to when
we were dating like there's a body like
my body's waiting for this thing and
it's different than a text message or
different than a facetime
um if y'all would commit to that you
keep doing the other stuff obviously
keep connecting and talking on facetime
your kids and all that but make that a
part of your routine right now how long
is your deployment
um it is about a year so i should be
home
tentatively
mid to late october okay
so
i want your wife i want you to strongly
encourage her and even if you don't have
the money i want you to figure out a way
to make this happen she needs to get
her own counselor right now that's gonna
help her and she may have that
but she's gonna have to learn some
resilience and strength not to take
what's happening personally that's a big
big deal with anyone who adopts kids
especially if you're dealing with
sexually abused or traumatized kids
because they're act out and it's at it
feels at you
because adults have hurt kids and
they're still parsing through are you
safe or not and so i'm gonna
explode here as though you're the new
bear
that just showed up to my cave
and or i'm gonna run or i'm gonna shut
down or i'm gonna fawn that's the other
one sometimes we mistake kids when they
nuzzle up on us and it feels so good and
they're with us that's actually a trauma
response too sometimes and so we're
going to take all of this behavior
whether really high really low or really
cute whatever and we're going to level
it out a little bit and we're going to
continue to say i'm safe i'm safe and
kids understand safety by i show up i
never yell
i don't deal in traffic and shame
and what i mean by that is oh my god you
crapped in your pants again it's
ridiculous you gotta kick control i
don't do that
i
say oh baby i'm so sorry we had an
accident same team same team let's get
this picked up let's get this cleaned up
and i've got a new pair of pants for you
and let's handle all of them that way
we're going to continue to plug back in
on safety and then
your wife's going to have to and this
may be hard
does she have a group of women around
her that she trusts that can come be
supportive
um there's some it's you know like with
being a parent it's kind of hard
sometimes and with me being deployed
people don't fully understand what's
going on especially when you have three
traumatized children in your life yes
so
this is a must not a
recommend recommendation she's got to
get some people around her
it's too heavy it's too heavy and this
isn't a statement about her strength
this is a statement about like i don't
care how strong you are you can't pick
up a f-250 by yourself this is what that
is and so there's got to be people that
will come over for an hour a day or hour
a week or two hours a week that will
pick somebody up from school or just
once a week drive kids to school or that
will show up and mow the yard and clean
the house something to give your wife
some sort of space that she can breathe
and
that space is gonna will build on itself
over time right now she doesn't have any
space to even breathe to even think
about how am i gonna be well in all of
this and the kids can't be well if you
and her aren't well so there's got to be
some sort of conversation and normally
brother
like that's hard to ask
because you think well i these are my
kids i adopted them i need to be able to
do this i should be able to figure this
out
and that's just too much man that's just
a myth and so having somebody
one two three four people around would
be
um
she's gotta have that gotta have that
gotta have that is that possible tell me
yes
yes sir okay it's humility and it's
starting it's being vulnerable but you
got to do it go ahead man sorry
yeah so her whole family lives
in hastings so that's
they're they're all super helpful like
your mother-in-law lives 100 yards up
the road oh that's awesome all right so
let's put this on the calendar
not let's wait until there's an
explosion in a terry i need mom i need
you right now to come down
let's put on the account every tuesday
at eight o'clock
mom shows up and i'm gone until 11.
and then i come back you know what else
you're going to teach your kids when you
do that
that love doesn't mean constant
never-ending connection
that mom this woman will leave and she
comes back every time
and dad he calls us every he's still
calling he's still checking in with us
he's still writing us letters he's
drawing us funny pictures he's sending
us silly books whatever
we're going to teach these kids that
there's a come and go to relationships
that's natural but these two kept
showing up these two kept showing up
these two kept showing up but i'll do a
real quick recap because i know we went
all over the place and i know rica i i
recap too much sometimes but
behavior is a language what is your baby
girl trying to tell you
take the
she's just doing this to get attention
or can take that language away
and reframe it
her body is trying to determine is are
you gonna hurt her too
and hurt can be
acute it can be abuse it can be
um i'm coming at you but it can also be
neglect are you going to show up i'm not
going to be stuck here again
and her body's trying to figure out what
that feels like her mind is trying to
feel what that feels like and you and
your wife are playing a 10 15 20 year
game
this is going to get hard and it's going
to get challenging and her body's going
to continue to say adults aren't safe
especially men and you my brother are
going to continue to say
yes i am
i'm going to keep showing up i'm going
to keep showing up i'm going to keep
showing up stay plugged into that
therapist stay plugged in the therapist
check out equine therapy
write your sweet sweet wi-fi a letter do
it every week we'll be right back
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john delony show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody and it's way
across town what do i do because i want
help with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
hey what's up we are back let's go to
carrie in phoenix hey arizona uh what's
up carrie
hey how are you doctor john dude dancing
like i have never danced before i'm
dancing on the ceiling lionel richie
style what are you doing
i am hiding in the closet so my toddler
doesn't know him
so good
so good man so what's up we'll talk
quietly so
well that's why i'm in the closet so i
can talk normal
so my husband is currently in the police
academy
um and this job is hard and we know that
we're not
we're not naive to that
but um we just want to know how we can
be proactive and preventative so we both
can have a mentally healthy
experience with this and it can be
positive for our family
wow
so why in the world
would anybody join the police force
right now
my husband wants to make a difference he
wants to be the good out there he's seen
the miracles that police officers can
provide for the people and he wants to
be a part of it he hates sitting behind
a desk and he wanted a job that had
purpose what a stud man what a great man
and what a great
partner that you are walking alongside
him it's incredible incredible okay
number one
thank you for
your service really
number two thank you for asking these
questions before so you guys have
already experienced something you all
thought you knew what it was going to be
then he goes to academy
and academy's
you know shocking all a little bit
walk me through what you guys are now
like you're feeling the rattling and
this job hasn't even started so
what are y'all experiencing already
that's making you go oh
ho what have we done
um i mean we're there's no regret at all
we are 110 into this
part of it i think is is seeing all the
unrest that's out there is we don't want
um we want we know that it's not all
going to be
unicorns and butterflies and great
experiences
um but we know that it can be a
a positive experience and so that's part
of it is seeing all of that so we just
knew going into it
um
it i think part of it too is my husband
has interacted with some people where
he's like wow not like some cops really
they have a hard time and they kind of
can
sometimes not stay as positive
and uplifting as people or they they end
up
we went to a family night and they're
like yeah a lot of cops end up divorced
and you know so it's just kind of has
the
uh
depressing around it um and so it's it's
not that we've necessarily had anything
happen we just hear about a lot of this
and we want to be able to come out on
top and with an intact marriage and
um and have learned and grown from it
and not just suffer through it you are
making my heart full that's so wise it's
so good for both of you for your
community phoenix is lucky to have a
couple like you too okay
so i'm gonna give you a lot and some of
this is ba i grew up in the house of a
homicide detective and a swat guy okay
so this is this is my family and
i've worked with police officers behind
closed doors for years
and even some research here so
i'm gonna give you a lot and i'll throw
it at you and you may not even have a
pen in the closet in the dark where
you're sitting hiding from your little
one but you can just go back and check
this story out and by the way for those
who are listening this applies not just
to police officers this applies to
new lawyers who are married this applies
to
nurses and nurse practitioners and new
physicians this applies to young
business owners
anybody who's put in a really stressful
situation with a young marriage and
little kids
it's easy for the wheels to start
rattling early on and if you don't deal
with it preventatively prophylactically
man like you said you talked to grizzled
exhausted old police officers i'm on
wife number three they keep her and you
think oh my gosh is this our destiny no
it's not it's not but you got to start
young you got to start soon so proud of
you okay
here's the two big ones for you okay
okay
never again
turn on the news or social media about
police officers
okay never again
over
you will get the information you need
about what's going on in your local
community in your local state from your
husband and from your friends
and that will be enough okay there is a
narrative
on one side of the equation that police
are infallible and perfect and we should
all bow
and that's inaccurate and false
and there's a narrative on the other
side that all police are evil and
ridiculous and awful and that is absurd
and
just
intractably false right
the goal of all that media is not to
pass along information that's true about
what's happening in the state of
policing in america the goal of that
information is to get your heart rate up
on either side of the equation to get
you fired up to get you to post back to
get you to keep clicking
and so as someone who loves a police
officer nobody will have more
information more on source than you so
you don't need them
opt out okay okay okay so be intentional
about that here's the second thing
there will come a season if it hasn't
already
that every time your phone rings or
there's a knock on your door
you're instantly going to go to worst
case scenario
my mom told me when i was 18 19 i wanted
to go to fbi and she said i'm asking you
as your mom
not to do that
and i said why she said well i'm
thinking about your future wife and when
you're 18 19 you're like whatever
and she said
every day of my life for the last 30
years
i your dad leaves and i think he may not
come home today
that's how the wheels are written that's
how all the information is stored in the
special fireproof box that every police
officer has in their home every day they
go to work they may not come home
and what i didn't understand was that
two people carry that
both the officer and the hardest part of
this is not knowing even the academy
it's not his life's on the line but i
never know how the day went i never know
if he passed his classes i never know
anything
and it's been hard to not have anxiety
over that yes so here's what i want you
to do i want you to carry a journal with
you keep it in your purse keep it
by your side use your notes app
and when you get these stories that pop
your head just write them down
write them down because you can't do
anything about them
and so we're going to write them down
and then i'm going to move on about my
day and that sounds ridiculous and it's
not going to stop it initially over time
your body will recognize oh she's in
control of these thoughts she's
controlling these stories there's no
reason to get worked up
and we're gonna let that breathe
okay
so those are your two number three for
you you have to have friends that aren't
cops wives
okay
you're gonna have to be hyper
intentional about that
your world will begin to skew everything
police and all police deal with all day
long is everybody else's worst case
scenarios
nobody calls the police just to invite
them to their house to give them gifts
we should do that
but we don't and so over time it's it's
common and it's normal for a police
officer who's running the beat 12 hours
a day
five 12's a week or whatever shifts
they're running
to
get a different view of the world
than is reality
okay when i say reality statistical
aggregation their reality is very very
real and when you hang out with wives
like that then it's all about
and you i want you to have people who
bring sunshine and joy into your life
okay
okay all right now here's what y'all can
do together
and this is super huge and this is all
about one word intentionality okay and
another word routine and another word
consistency that's three words
all right intentionality routine and
consistency commit to come hell or high
water come what may
starting today you and your husband are
going to have mental physical spiritual
and relational connectivity every day
make that part of your thing those
things could all be one minute each
it'd be better if they weren't
but if you i want you guys to build in
practices together that might be going
for a walk together and saying nothing
that might be y'all just do 10 push-ups
together that's it
it might be sex and intimacy it might be
you all go to the gym to get i don't
know what it is i don't know what what
your schedule allows if you're working
you got kids all that stuff
but you got to have some some physical
connectivity
got gotta be submissive you'll have to
have a time to talk to one another every
single day how are you and how are you
cops are notorious for trying to fix
everybody around them because that's
what they get called in to do every day
she's being mean to me and he tried to
punch me and the cop has to go solve
that problem as a math problem that does
not work with wife and kids
or with husbands and kids right so he
needs to sit down and listen to your day
you may want to read them your journal
you have your questions that popped up
or just say here's what happened today
and his only response can be thank you
so much for sharing i'm so glad you're
in this with me
and here's a fun story that happened
today
do you like hearing has he started doing
ride-alongs yet
um i think it starts out two weeks okay
so when i was
running around at night
in some of the most bonker situations
ever
i learned really quick
and i was not a police officer i was
on the payroll i was running adjunct to
them they were doing the hard stuff and
i was showing up with as a victim
services guy
i learned real real quick
those stories the things i was seeing
and experiencing
my wife did not need to hear
and i had to make sure i had other
places to go for me that was a counselor
for me that was a couple of close
friends for me that was a supervisor dr
andy young who was world class one of
the best ever ever
um your husband's gonna have to have
places where he can talk about what he
has seen what he has experienced that's
not you
you are not a trash can for what happens
and
i also went too far
and i completely cut my wife out of
these what i was experiencing
and we found ourselves two inches apart
on the couch and 5000 miles away from
each other
right so there's got to be some sort of
hey i saw something really hard and dark
last night that's messing with me and i
don't i i'm not into talking tonight can
we just hold hands and watch the office
that has to be a language you'll carry
with each other
okay
and you're gonna be like all right well
tell me what happened and he may tell
you the first time you're like well
that's the last time i want to hear
about that story right
and
um
and i'm talking about stories that you
we don't even imagine we couldn't even i
would not even even known that some of
that stuff was real until i saw it with
my own eyes
and to say it out loud
because you've seen it people around you
man
good grief we've been i mean we've had
meetings with james can't we it's like
oh yeah this happened one time and i
look around the whole room it's just
staring at me like what what are you
talking about and so you're gonna have
to know where what you can handle what
you don't want to handle it's not a
matter of your weakness not a matter of
you love him anything like that it's a
matter of we're gonna keep this thing
moving forward and then a weekly routine
never miss check-ins together what does
calendar look like
what's the status of your heart look
like
hey we haven't slept together in two
weeks we're going to put that on the
calendar because that's got to stay a
priority for us we haven't gone on a
date in 18 months because we have little
kids and i'm hiding in closets now we're
gonna have to make that stuff a priority
even when you're tired even when he's
tired y'all got to figure out ways that
y'all can connect
especially in the beginning
is that cool when he yeah and when he
does have the traumatic experiences is
talking to a counselor the best thing to
do are there other things he could do to
work through it so that he doesn't come
home and take it out on
and our kids
the
the come home and take it out on our
kids is a it's a myth and when i say
it's a myth that does happen but just
because you see and experience hard
things doesn't mean the kids are going
to get it so everybody deals with it
differently i'm equally concerned about
dads who come home with that kind of
stuff and check out
they just completely unplug and check
out
as i am with dad to come home and yell
and scream a lot
both of those things are traumatizing
especially the kids and especially the
spouses and so i'm less concerned with
he needs to do this thing
if he discharges his weapon
at somebody and hits them he will have
to go talk to somebody
um i'm more concerned with you guys
having a marriage counselor that y'all
can talk to regularly once a month
now that we've gone through that's
awesome and making sure y'all are
communicating together he just has to
have some sort of process and the thing
i told you about the mental physical
spiritual relational
that will give him rhythm and routine
and rhythm and routine and
intentionality creates resilience
and so when he these things happen
there is a
trampoline style floor he can land on
the landing doesn't smash him
right and the landing it gives him a
bounce so he can come back
and if you don't have those things
then when the first big one happens the
first time you walk into a room and see
multiple dead people and multiple
there's blood everywhere i mean when you
see some of that stuff
you got you hit the concrete right and
there's there's no bouncing back and
then the only thing to make that feel
better is another drink or texting an
old girlfriend or whatever the thing is
right that ends up with divorce and
divorce and divorce and divorce and
divorce so it's setting those things up
here's the final thing i want to pass
along to you guys this is going to sound
gross what i'm about to say
but i'm excited
you're a mom of a toddler there's no
such thing as gross for you
not gross in the
poop and pee kind of way but gross in it
feels transactional
i want y'all and this is from the great
therapist terry reel who's gonna be on
our show in a few uh i'm super excited
terry says an important thing to do is
to ask your husband
what needs of yours
can i meet
so that you can be available to meet my
needs
and that feels gross because it feels
roi
i'll scratch your back if you scratch
mine
and out of the gate it feels yucky
like all right what are the five things
you i i just have to do for you so that
you will plug back in and then he is
instantly going all right you do those
five things i'm gonna plug in and these
12 things and
what we're doing is we're practicing
this ons and offs
what are the things that turn on this
home for you
that make this place safe for you that
make you
feel sexual and desired that make you
laugh and that bring you joy you can
walk into your home and your shoulders
drop
i'm talking like in my house you know
what it is it's that when my wife is
gone and she's coming home in the
evening that the front porch lights are
on i don't know why that is but that's a
thing
and she sees those lights because my
driveway's really far into the woods
and she says she'll get tears in her
eyes as she drives up the driveway
knowing the home is gonna be warm it's
gonna be safe and that people are
waiting for to come home in a million
years if you had said write down ways
to
make your wife feel safe and loved i'd
not never have written down turn the
front porch lights on right so your you
and your husband are gonna sit down and
make a list what are things you need
from me
and there may be days that you circle
back to him and say hey you told me that
sex was important to you and we're on
week two
we need to do this and it's gonna sound
like hey you need to get your butt out
and mow the yard it's gonna feel like
that but we are
leaning into what does he need and he's
gonna lean into what does she need in in
short order this becomes a way of being
i'm walking into my home looking
scanning the room not for
what's out of place around here i'm
skiing the the room for how can i best
love my kids and my wife right this
second
and my wife has already thought through
that too and so i walk in and my
shoulders drop and then her shoulders
drop and now we're meeting each other in
a vulnerable connected way
dude it changes everything
what's hard for police officers is when
they come home
and they're back in another tent
situation because they've been tense all
day and what's hard for a wife is when
she's been tense and running around
earth's spouse husband's too
and then a husband comes home or the
wife comes home who's a police officer
and they're tense and then now the whole
house is tense right so that tension
works but let's just let that crap out
by saying
what do you need i'm gonna make it
happen but here's what i need to we're
gonna be open and we're gonna be honest
about that how does that sound
that sounds great thank you so much you
are
awesome i've talked at you like big time
for like 20 straight minutes without
even breathing i'm super passionate
about this because i know this if police
officers have
safe homes then our communities are
safer if they've got deep plugged in
connected relationships all of us win
and i know if things are messy at home
in any job things are messy at work i
can't be whole if i'm not whole at home
right can i just tell you carrie
you know how old are you
i'm 27.
they don't make them like you you're
incredible and i'm grateful for you
thank you for real just even having this
phone call even thinking down the line
so great and make sure he's got some
friends that aren't police officers too
okay
okay drag him along to your weird stuff
he's going to want to hang out with cops
and it's going to be cops and cops and
cops and i'm talking to you lawyers and
lawyers and lawyers and doctors and
doctors have some friends that do other
things
two of my closest friends one's a ceo of
a of a
lawn care company now after being the
chief information officer at some fancy
tech companies another one of my great
friends sells oil
he's a lube salesman not that we make
any jokes about that and one of my other
great friends is a
uh
caleb works at napa auto parts i've got
another buddy who's and craig's a banker
and everybody who works at hvac company
and i'm a freaking youtuber you know we
talk about everything
everything
[Music]
it's incredible we'll be right back
research has shown that the food you eat
directly impacts your mental and
physical health and that's why i'm a
maniac about putting good food into my
body and my family's body but we all
know that good food is super expensive
and when was the last time you went to a
butcher shop but my friends at
greensbury have solved it all greensbury
is a direct to consumer usda grade
organic meat provider right now they're
putting together a john d'alone starter
pack filled with my favorite cuts how
crazy is that rib eye steaks ground beef
chicken breast pork chops bacon salmon
you got it go to
greensbury.com to get 10 off your
starter pack sent to your door today
all right we got one more let's go to
the home of the great chuck liddell san
luis obispo california and talk to
jessica hey jessica what's up
hi john how are you so good how are you
i'm doing good
so what in the world is going on
well i have a question for you of how to
handle my husband um basically
back in 2000
the way you asked that was incredible
sorry
back in 2007 my husband and i were in a
situation where we had four kids and we
had paid off our house
so we were in a really good situation
so i wanted to work part-time and so we
were both working part-time
and it was working and then i wanted to
get a bigger house so
i made a deal with him i said if we can
get a bigger house i'll go back to work
full-time and then you can go and be a
stay-at-home dad again
so we did that and now it's 2022
the kids are older the youngest are in
10th in 12th grade and i would like him
to go back to work
and he refuses he says no you made a
deal
and you have to stick to it
you made a deal was this vegas what
he made a deal
the deal was
i wanted a bigger house
he was happy with the little house
i said
you know i personally i felt suffocated
i felt like a rat who was gonna you know
like go crazy one day in that tiny house
so i said okay if we get a bigger house
i'll go back to work full time and then
you can stay at home with the kids
and
now that the kids are older they don't
need him anymore at home he needs to go
in and
be
you know providing for the family too
oh man
he refuses he says no
you made a deal we're going to stick to
it the kids need me and i say no they
don't need you they're in 12th grade and
10th grade and they're good they don't
drink they don't smoke they don't do
drugs they don't have sex they don't do
they don't get in trouble with the
police they're there we've done our job
jessica they do all of those things they
just don't tell you i'm totally kidding
i'm telling you no they don't i know
they don't
like it so um
there's something way beneath this
yes there's lots of things way beneath
this trust me
i can i can feel it through the phone
can i just can i cut to it and you tell
me if i'm wrong
you absolutely
in no way shape form or fashion do you
have an ounce of respect for this man
that's yes that's the problem and that's
he doesn't he wants me to respect him
and to do what he says
and he gets a little
not he's not like mean but
you know he knows
that i don't give him the respect that i
should as a christian wife
and
the reason is because it's very hard to
respect a man who
doesn't want to take care of himself or
his family the way that i assume that a
man should want to do
so let's take the
christian wife baggage off of this for a
second let's just talk about human
dignity
okay okay this is a guy
i was going to ask you tell me about his
physicality
yes that is another problem is um the
reason why i want him to go back to work
is basically because
basically for the whole or we've been
married almost 27 years and for the past
27 years i've always been the one to
provide the health benefits through my
my working places
and
it's really frustrating to me because
he's overweight and he refuses to lose
his weight he just thinks it's funny and
he has type 2 diabetes and he's
expensive
and it's i feel that it's unfair that
i'm
shelling out an extra six thousand
dollars a year
to help pay for his medicine
and
he won't even you know provide for his
the cost of you know if he had a job in
california working 30 hours a week you
get benefits
so even if he worked yeah but i don't
care
this isn't about that so let me hear me
say
as clearly as i can
he needs to get his butt off the couch
and contribute
okay
i can't make
he's got to get off his butt and
contribute
contribution looks a different in all
sorts of ways
but he's got to contribute
but
you're talking about a vicious shame and
blame cycle that you all two have
created and this is probably a 25 year
dance
where why in the world would he want to
participate
in home building relationship
connectivity with somebody who acts like
his mom
who's always on him about you need to do
this and you do this and this is what i
signed up for and you're not the kind of
man or whatever and
why in the world would you want to
create a world with a guy
who's
literally killing himself slowly
diseases of despair this is a long tail
suicide i'm not gonna move i'm not gonna
have any purpose i'm gonna sit around
here and i'm gonna eat i'm not gonna
exercise my body's just gonna fall apart
on me
why would you want to connect to that
you see like both of you
are plugs and you've got the
those plug covers that you put when
there's newborns in the house
this is not happening
and right now you get into this world of
uh
blame and finger-pointing because you
don't like who you've become he didn't
like who he's become but there's nobody
there to anchor into because it's just
this loop-de-loop-de-loopty loop
have you found somebody else
nope
over 25 years
nope
so walk me through how lonely it's been
for a quarter of a century
well it's not that lonely don't forget
we have four kids no no that's not
that's not intimacy those are kids
true
well actually we do
we do have a lot of things in common
that we do like to do together and you
do have you've got a you've got a you've
got a
you can distract yourself
and he's probably funny and he's
probably fun to be around and you all
both like watching nascar whatever the
thing is
yeah but you don't like him
well i don't i don't know i mean he says
that sometimes he's like i don't think
you like me
i just met you you don't like him
you don't like him
so now what he may not
say it say it and he may not be likable
and so whenever we run up against this
this dance
somebody
somebody has to say enough i'm stopping
this
i'm stopping
but here's the thing
you cannot stop the dance
through finger-pointing and grenade
throwing you can only stop the dance by
saying what can i control in this dance
and the only thing you can control is
you
okay
and what do i do
you don't like you either
okay is that true am i wrong
maybe you like you you don't like who
you've become
yeah i guess i don't like i don't like
i don't know
i don't think i don't like me i think i
i
i feel like i got the short end of the
stick that's right you're this perpetual
victim you don't like where your life
has ended up and it's everybody else's
fault and you got you got a husband
who's not doing anything so there is
some contribution there make no mistake
okay
but what i want you to do is to stop
looking externally
for the solutions to why you feel the
way you feel inside
and instead say what can i control in
this situation
when's the last time
i exercised when's the last time i sat
down and
said the way you treat me and you
a guy i love the way you treat yourself
breaks my heart
and
i can't do anything about it so i'm
through fighting you i'm through yelling
at you
i'm not gonna sit here and just watch
you die
which is what you're doing you're
killing yourself in our living room i
can't be a part of that
i'm out what's kept you from doing that
um
actually we just had this conversation
not that long ago
so i did
explain to him that
you know he wasn't contributing enough
and it's not fair to me and i i trust me
we fight about the exercise and the
losing weight a lot
and i do exercise so i mean i've yeah
i've i've exercised
to the you know i was doing the whole
over 10 000 steps a day for a long long
time so i'm i do exercise and hike and
all of that my personal self i got that
but listen you started the conversation
with him about this isn't fair to me
that's correct it's a victim language
right it's not it's not power owning
language
i want you i want you to to take
your power back
and say take here i want you to take
ownership of yours
here's the problem that that i'm having
so
so
you know how you said that i was like
being the mother to him
he hates it when he's like you're trying
to be the boss you're trying to be in
charge of everything around here and
that's not your role and i say yes i
know and he's like i you know i'm in
charge blah blah blah blah what
listen you have a screwed up power
dynamic it's you versus him
and it's got to be all together
exactly and that's that's the thing so i
that's why so stop fighting you can't
win this 26 years try something new okay
twenty twenty six years i do
because i here's what i've tried in the
past i've tried
just shutting up and saying nothing i've
tried being a complete [ __ ]
i've tried um just doing my own thing
i've tried um
i've tried just pretending in my head
that he's on disability and there's
something wrong with him to just suck it
up and do it
i've tried pretending like he's hired
help and his job is to take care of the
kids so you can't expect anything else
like i've tried all of these things in
my head done the mental gymnastics but
the one thing you had all those things
mentioned you
and
mentioned him
talking about you okay
okay so tell me what i need to do
because i've i don't know what else to
do because i do
work all day
and then come home and do you know he
does a lot he does
um you know
make the dinners and he does you know do
stuff like that he takes the kids to
school and he does do the grocery
shopping and stuff like that he doesn't
do nothing completely but
i just
i mean
okay so the problem is that he's trying
to control the money too saying that i
shouldn't buy this i shouldn't do this
because
blah blah blah and i'm thinking well if
you had a job then we would have the
money to do that and we have money
that's what's frustrating
when i was
i don't know 22 23 college
i thought i was mr mma guy
and i thought honor and
power and strength was about flexing all
the time
i was always on the lookout for
who's disrespecting who and who can i
protect and
do you look at my wife i was that guy
what an idiot yeah what an idiot
and then after i spent a few years with
professional fighters their job their
paycheck is punching other people in the
face for money
i realized a few things number one
you never know
one of the worst beatings i ever took in
my life in training was from a 5-3
nurse named mateo and he worked me over
sideways i still remember it
and
here's what it did it humbled me in a
dramatic way
and
i started thinking huh
if i wait until
there's a
altercation which by the way never
happens
if i wait for an altercation to display
to my wife that i love her what a loser
i am so then i started displaying love
to my wife all the time
and what that freed me from was having
to flex it i just i'm not gonna fight
anybody i'm going home this is stupid
i'm leaving you say whatever you want
about me and my family congratulations i
hope you have a great day i'm out of
here that's not honor that's not
integrity that's cowardice in being a
child
so here's what i'm telling you
when i walk through the world looking
for oh yeah oh yeah
that's not that's not right step up
all i could see all day long was that
nonsense
and then when i said all right dude i'm
not i'm i'm just not i'm out
i can't describe the piece i just don't
i don't fight have a good day right and
here's what i'm telling you that
at some point you guys basically you're
saying to look for the good no no no no
not the bad you have to have an or what
moment and you haven't had it yet
okay
what does that mean are you gonna leave
no ever
no
there we are
so just suck it up no
suck it up is different than make peace
okay
okay
suck it up is different than make peace
suck it up is i'm gonna grip my teeth
i'm gonna grind my way through this
and peace is
i really love you
and i hate the fact that you're killing
yourself in our house
we have these goals together let's dream
about what this could look like
not about what's fair to me and fair to
you and who gets to control this and
control that
let's dream about what this could look
like
and well what if we have different goals
like he's completely satisfied with the
status quo of
of
his
his health he's completely satisfied
with the status quo how he how he keeps
house he doesn't think that it it needs
repairs and things like that
and
you know i would like to have people
over to the house but because he's so
messy i can't
why are you staying in this marriage
well
it's not a reason to get a divorce just
because somebody's messy
you know what i mean that's not a thing
that you would get a divorce over i know
but it's a thing that you are killing
yourself over
the age the rage and the anger and the
frustration and the constant
is killing you
yeah but that's not i mean there are
lots of people who have messy spouses
who don't get divorced over that that's
not a that's not a reason to get a
divorce so what is his like what is his
behavior trying to tell you
he's happy he doesn't he doesn't
he sees nothing wrong with
the way it is
he he doesn't he doesn't think that
his dad was very messy so he's very
messy so he doesn't when he looks at the
mess he doesn't see it the way i look at
it
and then he thinks that i'm trying to
keep up with the joneses and trying to
are you impress somebody
yeah i just want to be normal
i'm not trying to keep up with the
choices well and i just your picture of
normal again i'm not in your house i
can't see it and this may be a totally
different conversation
you all have a different definition of
what's normal and here's the thing
you're
have you heard me talk about pictures
and words
no
so
one of the chief challenges with all
marriages is that we think in pictures
but we speak in words
and you look at him
and you have a picture
of a lazy
respect-free slob who is wasting his
life and is keeping you from having
community and friends because of how he
lives
that's a picture in your picture
and your words you use to communicate
that are you're not healthy
you're not even you're a bum what are
you doing
and he's got a picture of what happy
looks like and that is i don't even have
to get a job my life's awesome we made
it i made a deal 30 years ago this is
incredible
and uh
it's cool my wife and i have some good
laughs and some good fun i saw how my
dad did it and that's pretty much what's
happening here i got great kids
we're doing something right i'm good
and what you haven't done for him y'all
you're using the same words and you're
just going right past each other so you
got to paint a picture
here is not like when he says when you
say i just want to be normal
he's saying i've got a picture of normal
and this is it and you're saying great
i've got a picture of normal and it
looks like her house or that guy's house
or it feels like people come over and
i'm not embarrassed
correct and so what you guys have to do
you got to do this
is you'll have to go
spend some time together painting a
picture here's what this means for me
and here's what this means for him and
what i'm telling you is this if he looks
at your picture and says i will never do
that
i don't love it
it's exhausting i'm scared i'm something
i will never do that
then you jessica have a decision to make
one of three choices
i'm going to nag him until he dies
i'm just going to continue to lean in
lean in lean in poke poke poke say it be
frustrated be angry
you can leave him which i don't think is
the right move
or
you can say
i love you enough to not like let you
just die like this
but i also know i can't make you
work
i can't make you be a participant in
this home
and it breaks my heart and i'm sorry
my picture for us is
that we have people over and the house
looks like this and here's an actual
picture
my picture is is that my husband doesn't
have type 2 diabetes because he doesn't
take care of his body he's not a good
steward of it
my picture is not that you treat me
fairly that you get your job and i get
my job and i've been giving you health
insurance
my
picture is is that we get back to
laughing really hard and that you like
me again and i like you again
and so the only thing i can control here
is that i'm just gonna start liking you
again for all of your quirks and
weirdness and whatever i am gonna hire
somebody to clean the house because i
want people over and you refuse to do
that so i'm gonna hire somebody to clean
the house
and that's gonna cut into some of your
video game time or your whatever time
and i am going to
fill in the blank i'm gonna start
backfilling some of these things
and you can choose to look at him as a
leech
as somebody who is sucking your soul out
of your life and he might be
but if you're not going to leave
then you can either choose to make peace
with what is
or
continue to go to war inside your body
every single day and what i'm telling
you is not just give up and i'm just
gonna tie
no i'm gonna start loving the guy
just in all of his goofy annoying
heartbreaking glory
and i'm gonna go about controlling the
things i can control
i'm going to let him know that he's
loved and that i'm heartbroken
i'm going to be frustrated
but i'm not i'm going to stop carrying
that stuff around because you're not
going to go you do love the guy you
don't like him but you love the guy
he's the dad of your kids he's done a
good job
he's
incredibly lazy unfathomably lazy
i don't know how he got untangled from
this and by the way you can make a new
deal you can say all right deal's over
now i'm making a new one
you're welcome to do that
but here's i'm trying to get you i'm not
trying to if he was on the phone i can
promise you'll be letting him have it
what i'm
want you to
come to realization is that nagging
complaining
throwing stuff at people
never ever works it doesn't work
and what it does in the process is it
drags you down
and i want you to get back to somebody
that you respect that you love that you
treat with dignity
and it's not through grinding it out and
exercise that's part of it but it's also
man i'm gonna give back to joy what are
things that bring me joy
being here doesn't bring me joy so i'm
gonna go do that stuff hiring somebody
and having people over every friday that
brings me joy i'm gonna start doing that
what are the things that bring you joy
because that's all you can control your
thoughts and your actions and let me be
honest i know this is super super hard
start back with you
we'll be right back
for the past two decades i've worked
with students parents those on the
margins and those who seem to have
everything i've met with law enforcement
military folks struggling single moms
company presidents and everybody in
between and there is one thread that
weaves through all of these different
people that you
me we
are so
lonely
we don't have real in-depth safe
relationships and hear me say this you
cannot be well alone
you can't do life by yourself you got to
get connected to real life people and
have deep relationships
i'm talking relationships where you can
be yourself share hard things
and know you'll show up for one another
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected because it's a key part of
living a good life
you'll learn why shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous you'll even
learn how to start making real friends
so go to johndaloni.com to take the next
step towards wellness that's own your
past change your future at
johndaloni.com
whew man
there's a couple hard calls my heart's
broken for everybody
that's hard man
that's hard hard hard
i
been
gonna ask you a real personal question
about your marriage but i won't do that
i just thought that'd be funny but i
would appreciate it you're welcome
by the way do you like your i'm just
kidding don't do that all right hey wrap
up today's show
man
again check it out own your pass change
your future it is available for pre-sale
johndalone.com and today man
from our friend dawn that works with us
here she takes care of all my speaking
engagement stuff she's incredible
songs by the rambling gambling man the
legends
the one and only bob seeger off the
stranger in town record
as long as i feel like a number and it
goes like this
i take my card and i stand in line to
make a buck i work overtime dear sir
letters keep coming in the mail i work
my back till it's racked with pain the
boss can't even recall my name i show up
late and i'm docked it never fails i
feel like just another spoke in the
great big wheel like a tiny blade of
grass and a great big field
and i feel like a number i feel like a
stranger a stranger in this land
i feel like a number i'm not a number
and you're not a number either we'll see
you soon